it is 431 431 done we are in San Jose
for WDC and the Cupertino Apple store
closes at 5 o'clock
right now it is 431 so we're trying to
do is we're trying to do a little WBZ
pregame we're trying to get to the store
before it closes
I'm shaking because I don't think we're
gonna make it in time it is you've never
even been here before no this is
actually my first WWDC this is also
Jenna's first WWDC but it's gonna be
your first time at the Cupertino Apple
[Music]
all right we made it hello hi good how
are you
we're actually after one incident loose
apple store right now and there's also
the atma visitor center which we went to
when the iPhone 10 does launch that
closes at 6 o'clock this one closes at 5
so we're gonna go here first and then
we're gonna go to the other one so come
on I can't any watch bands for tomorrow
what will look good on me two things
that looks really nice you think of this
one which one do you like better or do I
use this case for tomorrow what am I
gonna wear so these shirts are exclusive
to this store this is the original 1984
classic Mac which I just bought one from
eBay so I'm gonna be wearing this shirt
when I actually unbox it the best part
about this match is the 128 K in the 512
they have the entire Apple team
signatures in the back of it this is
such a cool design
do you want an Apple watch band Jenna
we'll get you present for Europe we got
Metis your birthday
oh my gosh they have pens and notebooks
and mugs they also have a rose gold yeah
what do I do
so get mugged we get a pen shoulda
brought a bigger suitcase real breasts
hmm I'm testing out the pen and I'm
going to leave I'm gonna leave my mark
oh wow it writes very nice sounds like a
good idea Jen duh d c18 how am I gonna
carry all this stuff home because I
don't have they're officially closed
they've been closed for two minutes
I might wear the t-shirt tomorrow it's
like I'm talking to myself I'm actually
looking at Jenna but it might look like
that I'm looking you guys okay I gotta
get a picture I'm gonna put it side by
side from the first time that I took a
picture here it was probably like
2007-2008 I just found all these old
pictures on my old laptop and let me
tell you it was wild
it's 5:14 this next Apple store which is
the visitor center to closed at 6
o'clock we've got our first bag of
purchases
I can't wait we want to keep those Apple
watch bands good thing we're going to
another store thank you
we made it to the visitor center let's
go take a look inside this place is so
beautiful they said they just extended
their hours so if it wouldn't have
extended the hours it would have been
closed
welcome I think I should get a bag to
put all the things in the diapers
what do you think so we know anybody's
baby no she just said I'm the best
vlogger so you guys hurting here first
this is so great I'm having the best
time I'm gonna be wrong Mela mercy Mela
Morsi ha ha ha
and this is my favorite color
Wow those look so good we should get
these Apple watch bands though I think
they look really good because they do
have those this is my favorite color
I'm gonna get you a gift do you want to
get I'm gonna get Jenna again
a gift for Jenna gift for Justine
I lost Justine I had to find her
I found her she's the one carrying all
the things I'm sorry we should get like
a smack at the as the Matt cafe always
oh my I'm having really a really really
fun time
no lovely news they actually close at
7:00 we thought they close at 6:00 so
we're gonna do with this seven we're
gonna do yeah I know we're gonna do the
Matt cafe I'm gonna take you upstairs on
the roof to get a really cool panoramic
picture and then I'm gonna take you into
the other last room which is surprised
do you want like some they have almonds
oh well we should go Oh what should we
get so here we have the menu on an iPad
what would you like Jen nitro cold brew
I have a coffee already I probably
shouldn't get another one okay I'll just
do that but okay we're gonna see Apple
this chocolate this is a matcha
chocolate it's really hot in the Sun
like
that is a lovely taste here oh this is
this is nice the milk chocolate okay no
pressure do a half
Wow really good oh my it's lovely
let's go to the roof roof
I mean this store is just incredible yes
oh yes I'll see you here it is wow it's
so pretty I don't me also say fourth
roof okay so we're leaving the upstairs
and now we're heading down and they have
an entire 3d rendering of the Apple
Campus you use the iPad and so using AR
you can scan the entire campus and it
will do really cool animations I showed
you guys this before my previous video
but Jenna hasn't seen it and that's it
that's a wrap on or San Jose Cupertino
Apple store visit WIC
coming up very very soon boy I can't
wait to put on my new Apple watch band
okay that's the other video
[Music]